yes
[Music]
this
yes
[Music]
hi i'm jason and jason lee uh from cmu
like i got my experience
and i'll be talking about
pre-conditioning and analysis design
in this talk we'll be considering uh a
bunch of like fundamental classic graph
graph problems for example graph cut
problems like like min cut
and actually all types of ink all
variants of mental problems
and also some special graph theory
problems like conductance and expanders
and also um we'll briefly look at some
graph distance problems like
shortest path of course response is easy
in sequentially so we're looking at sort
of unparalleled
and
problems with similar flavor
and the two techniques we'll we'll be
using to attack these problems are
pre-conditioning and locality so
preconditioning let's first begin with
pre-conditioning so pre-conditioning has
its roots in numerical linear algebra
where it's um the common technique is to
pre-condition a matrix in some linear
system
but in the context of graph algorithms i
like to think of preconditioning as a
distinction between worst case and
average space
so pre-conditioning is
is uh the technique is um is about
preconditioning a general case problem a
worst case problem to behave like an
average case problem so that kind of
allows us to kind of assume that the
input is um random
and
of course random random inputs um
are just random we want to kind of
exploit some kind of structure from them
and the structure that we want to
exploit depends on the problem uh
problem context of course so for graph
cut problems we'll be exploring the fact
that random graphs are expanders
and for distance problems we'll be using
that random graphs have low aspect ratio
and of course
um
once we solve the the random problem we
want to reduce general uh general
instances two random instances and here
for the graph cut problems one common
technique we use is expander
decomposition this is a decomposing
general graph do expanders by deleting a
small number of edges in between because
the red edge in between is a small
fraction of edges
and historically this this concept of
pre-conditioning in the condo's graph
outcomes has been was popularized by
spielman tang and their seminal result
on solving the pattern systems quickly
that's that's it for preconditioning for
locality
so locality has its roots in local
algorithms local graph algorithms and
these are algorithms which
begin with some seed vertex v and just
explore a small neighborhood around v so
in particular the running time of a
local album is much smaller than the
entire graph so it does not look at the
entire graph
so typically a good local algorithm will
run in time further to the side the
smaller side of some cut it wants to
find
and practically it's like sublinear in
the in the input size
and one famous example of a logarithm is
pagerank nibble which computes the
product conductance
in this talk we'll be looking at
locality not from like this local
algorithm model but as a fundamental
principle in algorithm design so how can
we how can we use locality exploit
locality to obtain faster arms in the
classical setting
so what we think of locality as a
distinction between unbalanced cases and
balance cases
so
whereas preconditioning we assume that
the input graph is random
in the locality instant case we assume
that the target solution is local to
some vertex in particular suppose
suppose the target solution is a graph
cut
we're assuming that the graph cut is
local
to some vertex v that we may or may not
know
and of course once again
it's not enough to just assume unbalance
we want to reduce
general instances to unbalanced and this
here there are some
here uh
our techniques depend on the problem
sometimes we can maintain a straight
reduction and sometimes you have to
handle the balance case separately and
exploit additional structure from the
balance case
these are two problems
and okay so for the remaining of this
remainder of this talk i want to kind of
like make a case for these two problems
do these two techniques
uh in other words why do these
techniques are cool and why we should
care about them
so for one
i claim that these these techniques are
powerful they've resolved they have been
made they have made progress on
these classic uh
classic graph cut and distance problems
for example
it has led to the current fastest
algorithms for for example various min
cut
various min cut problems
um
parallel shortest path
uh also like deterministic expanded
decomposition which itself
um
was used for determinants of
preconditioning and so on
it's also versatile it
it applies to all types of graph
problems for example in the particular
case of min cut it up that we were able
to apply for practically every single
variant of input so we saw it
and finally i want to claim it's cutting
edge uh no pun intended then
in other words these problems are have
most these techniques have mostly been
unexplored in the past which is
significant because that concerns future
potential
in other words these techniques have a
lot a lot of future room to grow and
develop
and this will be the hardest uh
claim to make and for the rest of the
talk i want to kind of like give a feel
of how
simple these results are some how simple
some of these algorithms are they say
that there are algorithms
and that's significantly because a
simple algorithm that has remained
undiscovered for so long is usually a
sign that
what we lack in the past was not
the right technical tools but the right
perspective
so this is a matter of perspective not
developing like concrete technical tools
okay so the problem will be considering
for the rest of the talk is steiner main
card
and this is a it's a it's a similar
simple generalization of like say global
women card where statement cut given a
graph and a subset of term on vertices
called terminals
find the main card that serves at least
two terminals
so for example
if this is if the set r is just s and t
is sd min cut
if set r is every all the vertices it's
gold
and historically this problem has been
studied in the comments of gamma hutry
which is no or in other words all paris
meaning cut
and the fastest algorithm
um is
one running time m plus nc squared where
c is the size of the the target main
current
this is dynamic
so to solve this problem
we're making almost like a leap of faith
we'll be considering we'll be assuming
that the steiner mint cut
is unbalanced but in fact so unbalanced
that there's only one terminal on one
side so this blue cut here has only one
term on this side
now of course
at first glance
this assumption does not seem to be
that fruitful of an assumption like why
why um
[Music]
why do unbalanced cuts capture the
general
case and also what we can gain from
assuming such an assumption and in fact
like when when i started work on this
problem
um
i had no idea either all i knew was that
locality was a useful concept it's been
successful in the past let's just try
here
that turned out
it turned out to be the this this key
assumption turned out to be the key step
in the entire algorithm after we we
assumed this everything else almost felt
almost off
almost came together uh immediately
so in particular why is this um general
enough turns out you can reduce general
cases to this unbalanced case by random
sound
and we'll see you later it's very simple
okay so
so the theorem i want to cover in the
last like three or so minutes
is that
um for first of all the unbalanced
dynamin cut can be solved in polylog mag
slopes
so
so this requires um so this for this we
define a new problem but essentially
captures the unbalanced case
um
and we essentially gave a simple
algorithm to solve this problem in log
and max flows
and then in general
for the general case we reduced the
the um
the general case to the to the
unbalanced case by simple random
sampling
so first let's go over the unbalanced
case
so here essentially the problem we want
to consider
is this minimum isolating
problem which is giving us given the
graph in the terminals find for each
terminal
the min cut that separates that term
essentially we know the cut is
unbalanced we don't know which terminals
on the unbound side so just try number
one this is essentially the problem
and trivially it will take ironman cuts
the size of our main cuts that's the
main product to solve but
we show a very simple algorithm that
uses log r estimates
um and this album's actually very simple
um if i had five or minutes i would have
shown it i hadn't proved it it's like
two pages long in the paper
and it implies non-balanced dynamic
and finally how do we reduce general
assignment unbalanced well it turns out
we just need a random sample at
appropriate sampling scale
so if we sample a rate let's say one
over the size of s intersect r the
number of terminals in the small in
let's say the smaller side of the target
min cut
then with constant probability we'll sum
exactly one and we'll just call this
minimum isolating the unbalanced case on
the subsample and get the right answer
and of course we don't know which scale
to sample but we understand what like uh
geometry increasing scales
so re as a recap what happened was
we assumed this locality assumption that
assignment is unbalanced one term on one
side
we formulate a problem
and um that captured that instance and
solved it
um and then finally we we stopped a
simple reduction from general steiner
min cut to this unbalanced case by
random sample in terms of this steiner
min cut this simple algorithm is state
of the art we've previously
nothing was known
even in like sub-linear in our max
fields so nothing non-trivial was known
in the general case first language
so level so finally last slide what
would be randomization
so what if we want to de-randomize that
random sampling step in this dynamic cut
so it turns out here it's it's not so
clear how to derive in general
but what we're going to exploit is that
if g is an expander now i have to it's a
bit more technical to define what it
means to be expanded with respect to a
subset r but let's just forget about
that further talk
um
if g is some sort of expander then the
steiner min cut is guaranteed
to have a small number of versions on
one side
and the intuition is basically if the
sound wasn't balanced then it
automatically becomes a little connected
cut and it cannot be expanded
contradiction that's the intuitive thing
and it turns out that unbalanced case in
the unbalanced case in this in this case
it means like not one vertex but like
some polylog number vertices on a
smaller side that's easy to randomize
this is standard derivative
randomization tools and finally to get
the general case we we pre-conditioned
the graph by expanded decomposition so
it's essentially we only need to solve
this matter case so that so essentially
this determinant standard cut
problem required both locality and
pre-conditioning dissolved
so that's that's it for my talk um
again this is the
this year's list of problems i look at
so far and
um
yeah thanks for listening
[Applause]
so
you